SPEAKER 1: So, Colson Whitehead
is "The New York Times"
best-selling author
of "The Noble Hustle,"
"Zone One," "Sag Harbor,"
"The Intuitionist,"
"John Henry Days,"
"Apex Hides the Hurt,"
and one collection of
essays, "The Colossus
of New York," a
Pulitzer Prize finalist
and a recipient of the MacArthur
and Guggenheim fellowships.
He lives in New York City.
And today we're so lucky to
have him in the Bay Area.
We're getting him
on a great day,
as "The Underground
Railroad" was just
chosen to be on the long list
for the National Book Award
this year.
So with that, please welcome
Colson Whitehead to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
COLSON WHITEHEAD:
Thank you, kind sir.
Thanks to y'all for coming out.
The book is called "The
Underground Railroad."
I first had the idea for
it about 16 years ago.
I was laying on my couch, as I
like to do in the afternoons,
nursing a depression, and
came across a reference
to the Underground
Railroad and thought, oh,
isn't it funny how
when you're a kid
and you first hear those
words, it's so evocative.
You think it's a literal
railroad underground.
And of course, you find out that
it's not, and you're quite sad.
So that's a premise, not
much of a story there.
So I kept thinking about it,
and I sort of added, well,
what if each state
our protagonist
goes through-- South
Carolina, North Carolina--
is a different state of
American possibility,
as in "Gulliver's Travels,"
sort of a natural comparison.
And that was the story.
And I didn't feel up to
writing it 16 years ago.
I didn't feel ready.
I sort of assumed I
would screw it up.
But if I put it off and maybe
tried again later with a few
more books under my belt,
a little more mature,
it might actually turn out OK.
So each time I finished a
book, I would go to my notes
and try to figure
out if I was ready.
And the answer was
would always be no,
until about 2 1/2 years ago.
I had an idea for a book
that was all ready to go.
I had sold it to my editor.
And I decided to tell my wife
about this Underground Railroad
idea and see what she thought.
And she said, I
don't want to say
that your idea about a
Brooklyn writer going
through a mid-life
crisis is dumb per se,
but this Underground Railroad
book sounds really good.
So that was one person.
And then I went to my agent,
who I've been with for 18 years
through thick and thin, and
I told her about the idea.
And she said, well,
both ideas sound good,
which is not very helpful.
But then she emailed
me two days later,
which she never
does, and said, I've
been think about the
Underground Railroad idea,
and maybe you should pursue it.
So that was two people.
I went to my shrink,
told her the idea.
And she was like,
what are you, crazy?
I mean, we both
know you're crazy,
but I think this Underground
Railroad story is up
your alley.
And so I went to
my editor, to whom
I'd already sold that book
about the writer going
through a mid-life crisis,
and he responded with,
giddy up, motherfucker,
which is publishing for,
I think that's a good idea.
You should pursue it.
So I did.
The story is about Cora, a young
girl in a plantation in Georgia
running North.
In this first section I'll read,
she's on her home plantations.
She's a stray, an orphan, in
the parlance of the plantation.
Her mother has run
off years before,
and she has no relatives.
She's about 16 or 17.
She's not entirely sure
because slave masters
didn't keep track of
their slaves' ages,
in the same way you might
know that your dog Scruffy is
eight years old and not
know his exact birthday.
There's a man named
Caesar, who's come,
a new slave on the plantation.
He was raised in Virginia
on a small family farm
and was promised that when his
master died, he would be freed.
Unfortunately, is master's
niece had other plans and sort
of liquidated him and his
parents along with the rest
of her aunt's possessions.
And he's sold down South,
which is always terrible
because the South is-- that the
slave system is more and more
brutal the more south you go.
So he's come to this
plantation where Cora is.
It's owned by the two Randall
brothers, James and Terrance.
And this section,
it's the birthday
of a man named Old Jockey, the
oldest slave on the plantation.
And whenever he
senses that there's
a need for a pick-me-up
on the plantation,
things are getting bad and
people need to release,
he says it's my
birthday, and they
have a birthday feast for him.
And it could be once a
year, twice a year, but they
have a big celebration
and they have dancing.
And the last person
to introduce is
a kid named Chester, who's a
10-year-old and has no family,
and Cora has sort of
taken him under her wing.
"The music stopped.
The circle broke.
Sometimes a slave will be lost
in a brief eddy of liberation,
in a sway of a sudden
reverie among the furrows
or while untangling the
mysteries of an early morning
dream, in the middle of a
song, on a warm Sunday night.
Then it comes always,
the overseer's cry,
the call to work, the
shadow of the master,
the reminder that she's only
human being for a tiny moment
across the eternity
of her servitude.
The Randall brothers had
emerged from the great house
and were among them.
The slaves stepped aside,
making calculations
of what distance represented
the right proportion of fear
and respect.
Godfrey, James's house
boy, held up a lantern.
According to Old
Jockey, James' favored
the mother, stout
as a barrel and just
as firm in countenance.
And Terrance took after the
father, tall and owl-faced,
perpetually on the verge
of swooping down on prey.
In addition to the
land, they inherited
their father's tailor,
who arrived once
a month in a rickety carriage
with his samples of linen
and cotton.
The brothers dressed alike
when they were children
and continue to do
so into manhood.
Their white trousers
were as clean
as the laundry girls'
hands could make them,
and the orange lantern glow
made them look like ghosts
emerging from the dark.
'Master James,' Jockey said,
his good hand gripped the arm
of his chair as if to
rise, but he did not stir.
'Master Terrance.' 'Don't let
us disturb you,' Terrance said.
'My brother and I were
discussing business and heard
the music.
I told him, now that is the
most god-awful racket I've ever
heard.'
The Randalls were drinking wine
out of goblets of cut glass
and looked as if they'd
drained a few bottles.
Cora searched for Caesar's
face in the crowd.
She did not find him.
He hadn't been
present the last time
the brothers appeared
together on the northern half.
You did well to remember
the different lessons
of those occasions.
Something always happened
when the Randalls ventured
into the quarter,
sooner or later,
a new thing coming
that you couldn't
predict until it was upon you.
James left the daily
operations to his man Connolly
and rarely visited.
He might grant a
tour to a visitor,
a distinguished neighbor,
or a curious planter
from another neck of the
woods, but it was rare.
James rarely
addressed his niggers,
who'd been taught by
the lash to keep working
and ignore his presence.
When Terrance appeared on
his brother's plantation,
he usually appraised each
slave and made a note
of which men were
most able and which
women were most appealing.
Content to leer at
his brother's women,
he grazed heartily upon
the women of his own half.
'I like to taste my
plums,' Terrance said,
prowling the rows of cabins
to see what struck his fancy.
He violated the
bonds of affection,
sometimes visiting slaves
on their wedding night
to show the husband
the proper way
to discharge his marital duty.
He tasted his plums and broke
the skin and left his mark.
It was accepted that James was
of a different orientation.
To hear his valet
Prideful tell it,
James confined his erotic
energies to specialized rooms
in a New Orleans establishment.
The madam was
broad-minded and modern,
adept in the trajectories
of human desire.
Prideful's stories were hard
to believe, despite assurances
that he received his reports
from the staff of the place,
with whom he'd grown
close over the years.
After all, what
kind of white man
would willingly
submit to the whip?
Terrance scratched
his cane in the dirt.
It'd been his
father's cane, topped
with a silver wolf's head.
Many remembered its
bite on their flesh.
Terrance said,
'then I recollected
James telling me about a
nigger he had down here
could recite the
Declaration of Independence.
I can't bring myself
to believe him.
I thought perhaps
tonight he can show me,
since everyone is out and
about, from the sound of it.'
'We'll settle it,'
his brother said.
'Where is that boy Michael?'
No one said anything.
Godfrey waved the lantern
around pathetically.
Moses was the boss
unfortunate enough
to stand closest to
the Randall brothers.
He cleared his throat,
'Michael dead, Master James.'
Michael, the slave in
question, had indeed
possessed the ability
to recite long passages.
According to Connolly, who
heard the story from the nigger
trader, Michael's former
master was fascinated
by the abilities of
South American parrots,
and reasoned that if a bird
could be taught limericks,
a slave might be taught
to remember as well.
Merely glancing at
the size of the skulls
told you that a nigger possessed
a bigger brain than a bird.
Michael had been the son
of his master's coachman,
had a brand of animal
cleverness, the kind
you see in pigs sometimes.
The master and
his unlikely pupil
started with simple
rhymes and short passages
from popular British versifiers.
They went slow over the words
the nigger didn't understand
and, if truth be told, the
master only half understood.
But they made miracles,
the tobacco farmer
and the coachman's son.
The Declaration of Independence
was their masterpiece.
Michael's ability never amounted
to more than a parlor trick,
delighting visitors before
the discussion turned,
as it always did, to
the diminished faculties
of niggers.
His owner grew bored
and sold the boy South.
By the time Michael
got to Randall,
some torture or punishment
had addled his senses.
He was a mediocre worker.
He complained of
noises and black spells
that obscured his memory.
In exasperation,
Connolly beat out
what little brains he had left.
It was a scourging that Michael
was not intended to survive,
and it achieved its purpose.
James said, 'I should have been
told,' his displeasure plain.
Michael's recitation had been
a novel diversion the two times
he trotted the nigger
out for guests.
Terrance liked to
tease his brother.
'James,' he said, 'you
need to keep better account
of your property.'
'Don't meddle.'
Terence continued,
'I knew you let
your slaves have their
revels, but I had no idea
they were so extravagant.
Are you trying to make me look
bad?' 'Don't pretend you care
what a nigger thinks about you,
Terrance.' James' glass was
empty.
He turned to go.
'Oh, one more song, brother.
These sounds have grown
on me,' Terrance said.
George and Wesley, the
musicians, were forlorn.
Noble and his tambourine
were nowhere to be seen.
James pressed his
lips into a slit.
He gestured, and the
men started playing.
Terrance tapped his cane.
His face sank as he
took in the crowd.
'You're not going to dance?
I have to insist--
you and you and you.'
They didn't wait for
their master's signal.
The slaves of the northern
half converged on the alley
haltingly, trying to
insinuate themselves
into their previous
rhythm and put on a show.
Putting on a show for
master was a familiar skill,
the small angles and
advantages of the mask.
And they shook off
their fear as they
settled into the performance.
Oh, how they capered and
hollered, shouted and hopped.
Certainly, this was the most
lively song they'd ever heard.
The musicians, the most
accomplished players
the colored race had to offer.
Cora dragged herself
into the circle,
checking the Randall brothers'
reactions on every turn,
like everyone else.
Jockey tumbled his hands
in his lap to keep time.
Cora found Caesar's face.
He stood in the shadow of the
kitchen, his expression flat.
Then he withdrew.
'You.' It was Terrance.
He held his hand
before him as if it
were covered in some eternal
stain that only he could see.
Then Cora caught sight of
it, the single drop of wine,
staining the cuff of
his lovely white shirt.
Chester, the boy,
had bumped him.
Chester simpered and bowed
before the white man,
'Sorry, Master.
Sorry, Master.' The cane crashed
across his shoulder and head
again and again.
The boy screamed and
shrank to the dirt,
as the blows continued.
Terrance's arm rose and fell.
James looked tired.
One drop.
A feeling settled over Cora.
She'd not been under
its spell in years,
ever since she brought
the hatchet down
on Blake's doghouse and sent
the splinters into the air.
She'd seen men hung from
trees and left for buzzards
and crows, women carved up
open to the bones with the cat
o'nine tails, feet cut
off to prevent escape
and hands cut off to stop theft.
She'd seen boys
and girls younger
than this beaten that
had done nothing.
This night, the feeling
settled on her heart again.
It grabbed hold of her.
And before the slave
part of her caught up
with the human part of her, she
was bent over the boy's body
as a shield.
She held the cane in her hand,
like a swamp man handling
a snake, and saw the
ornament at its tip.
The silver wolf bared
its silver teeth.
Then the cane was
out of her hand.
It came down on her head.
It crashed down again.
And this time, the silver
tooth ripped across her eyes,
and her blood
splattered the dirt."
This next a brief reading is
about a woman named Ethel.
[INAUDIBLE] escaped a
plantation and moves
to South Carolina
and North Carolina.
In North Carolina, in
this alternative history
of that state, the
government has come up
with a final solution to solve
the problem of the Negro, which
is to abolish Negroes.
And if you're caught in the
street, you can be killed,
lynched.
The people doing the work
of the slaves, because there
are no slaves now,
are Irish immigrants,
who are taking over the work
and will become assimilate
into American society.
Martin is a reluctant
abolitionist.
His father worked in
Underground Railroad.
And one day, when he was putting
his father's affairs in order
after his father dies,
he gets a message
that there's someone
waiting in the railroad.
And that's how he discovers that
his father is an abolitionist,
and he ends up being
an accidental conductor
on the Underground Railroad.
His wife Ethel is
even more reluctant,
and this is her story.
And it ends with Cora
hiding in their attic
because she can't
get a passage out
of North Carolina for a while.
"Ever since she saw a woodcut
of a missionary surrounded
by jungle natives,
Ethel thought it
would be spiritually
fulfilling to serve
the Lord in dark Africa,
delivering savages
to the light.
She dreamed of the
ship that would
take her, a magnificent schooner
with sails like angel wings,
cutting across the violent
sea, the perilous journey
into the interior, up rivers,
wending mountain passes,
and the dangers escaped-- lions,
serpents, man-killing plants,
duplicitous guides--
and then the village,
where the natives receive her
as an emissary of the Lord,
an instrument of civilization.
In gratitude, the niggers
lift her to the sky,
praising her name--
Ethel, Ethel.
She was eight years old.
Her father's
newspapers contained
tales of explorers, unknown
lands, pygmy peoples.
The nearest she could get to
the image in the newspaper
was playing "missionary
and native" with Jasmine.
Jasmine was like
a sister to her.
The game never lasted
long before they switched
to the game of "husband
and wife," practicing
kisses and arguments in the
cellar of Ethel's house.
Given the color of
their skins, there
was never any doubt
over the roles
in either game, Ethel's habit
of rubbing soot into her face,
not withstanding.
Her face blackened, she
practiced expressions
of amazement and wonder
in front of the mirror
so that she'd know
what to expect
when she met her heathens.
Jasmine lived in the upstairs
room with her mother Felice.
The Delaney family
owned Felice's mother.
And when Edgar
Delaney turned 10,
he received Felice as a present.
Now that he was a
man, Edgar Delaney
recognized that
Felice was a miracle,
tending to the
affairs of her house
as if she were born to it.
He recounted her darky wisdom
as a matter of routine,
sharing her parables
about human nature
with guests whenever she
disappeared into the kitchen.
So that when she
returned, their faces
glowed with affection
and jealousy.
He gave her passes to visit
the Parker plantation every New
Year's Day feast.
Felice's sister was
a washerwoman there.
Jasmine was born nine
months after one such visit,
and now the Delaneys
owned two slaves.
Ethel thought that a slave was
someone who lived in your house
like family but was not family.
Her father explained
the origin of the Negro
to disabuse her of
this colorful idea.
Some maintained
that the Negro was
a remnant of a race
of giants who ruled
the earth in an ancient time.
But Edgar Delaney knew
that there were descendants
of cursed black Ham,
who had survived
the flood by clinging to the
peaks of a mountain in Africa."
This was actually a real
belief of racists in the 1830s.
It's crazy.
"Ethel thought that
if they were cursed,
they required Christian
guidance all the more.
On her eighth birthday,
Ethel's father
forbid her to play
with Jasmine so as not
to pervert the natural state
of relations between the races.
Ethel did not make
friends easily, even then.
She sobbed and stomped for days.
Jasmine was more adaptable.
Jasmine assumed simple
duties around the household
and took over her
mother's position
when Felice's heart seized and
she fell mute and paralyzed.
Felice lingered for months,
her mouth open and pink,
eyes foggy until Ethel's
father had her removed.
Ethel observed no disturbance
in her old playmate's face
when they loaded her
mother into the cart.
By then, the two did not speak
outside of household matters.
The house had been
built 50 years before,
and the stairs creaked.
A whisper in one room carried
over into the next two.
Most nights after
supper and prayers,
Ethel heard her father going
up the crooked stairs, guided
by the bobbing
light of his candle.
Sometimes she sneaked
to her bedroom door
and caught a glimpse of
his white bed clothes
disappearing around the corner.
'Where are you going,
father?' she asked one night.
Felice had been gone two years.
Jasmine was 14.
'Going upstairs,' he said.
And both experienced
a strange relief now
that they had a term for
his nocturnal visits.
He was going upstairs.
Where else did the stairs lead?
Her father had given
one explanation
for the separation of races
and fratricidal punishments.
His nighttime trips
elaborated on the arrangement.
Whites lived downstairs,
and blacks lived upstairs.
And to bridge that separation
was to heal a biblical wound.
Her mother had
held a low opinion
about her husband going upstairs
but was not without resources.
When her family sold
Jasmine to the coopersmith
on the other side of town, Ethel
knew it was her mother's doing.
There was no more going upstairs
when the new slave took up
residence.
Nancy was a grandmother, slow
in her steps and half blind.
Now it was her wheezing that
penetrated the walls, not
footsteps and squeals.
The house had not been so
orderly and clean since Felice.
Jasmine had been
efficient but distracted.
Jasmine's new home was across
the way in colored town.
Everyone whispered that the
child had his father's eyes.
One day over lunch,
Ethel announced
that when she was
old enough, she
intended to spread the Christian
word to African primitives.
Her parents scoffed.
It was not something that good
young women from Virginia did.
'If you want to help savages,'
her father said, 'teach school.
The brain of a five-year-old
is more savage and unruly than
the oldest jungle
darky,' he said.
Her course was set.
Ethel filled in for
the regular teacher
when she was under the weather.
Little white children were
primitive in their own way,
chirping and undeveloped,
but it wasn't the same.
Her thoughts of the jungle
and a ring of dark admirers
remained in her
private preserve.
Resentment was the hinge
of her personality.
The young women in her
circle comported themselves
in a foreign ritual
undecipherable.
She had little use for
boys and later men.
When Martin appeared,
introduced by one of her cousins
who worked at the
shipping company,
she tired of the gossip
and long relinquished
an interest in happiness.
A panting badger,
Martin wore her down.
The game of husband and
wife was even less fun
than she supposed.
Jane, her daughter,
at least, turned out
to be an unexpected mercy,
a tidy bouquet in her arms.
Over the years, life
on Orchard Street
passed into a tedium
that eventually
congealed into comfort.
She pretended not to see Jasmine
when they passed on the street,
especially when
her former playmate
was in the company of her son.
His face was a dark mirror.
Then Martin was summoned
to North Carolina.
He arranged his father's funeral
on the hottest day of the year.
They thought Ethel fainted
from sadness, when it was just
the barbaric humidity.
Once they got a taker for
his father's feed shop,
they were done, he assured her.
The place was backward.
If it wasn't the heat,
it was the flies,
if not the mice,
then the people.
At least in Virginia
lynch mobs maintained
a pretext of spontaneity.
They didn't string
up people practically
in your front lawn the same
time every week, like church.
North Carolina was to
be a brief interlude,
or so she thought, until
she came across the nigger
in her kitchen.
George had dropped out of
the attic for some food,
the lone slave Martin
helped before Cora arrived.
It was a week before the
race laws went to effect,
and violence against
the colored population
was on the rise in rehearsal.
A note on their doorstep
had directed Martin
to the mica mine,
where the railroad is,
and George waited for
him, hungry and irritated.
The tobacco picker thumped
around the attic for a week
before a railroad agent
took him on the next leg,
boxing him up in a crate
and shoving the thing
through the front door.
Ethel was livid,
then despairing.
George acted as Martin's
father's executor,
illuminating Martin's
secret inheritance.
Slavery is a moral issue
and never interested Ethel.
If God has not meant for
Africans to be enslaved,
they wouldn't be in chains.
She did, however,
have firm ideas
about not getting killed
for other people's
high-minded ideas.
She and Martin argued over
the Underground Railroad
as they hadn't argued
in a long time.
And that was before
the murderous fineprint
and the race laws
manifested itself.
Through Cora, that
termite in the attic,
Martin's father reached
from beyond the grave
to punish her for her joke
those many years before.
When Martin went upstairs
to help the girl,
it was not in the same way
her father had gone upstairs.
But both men came
down transformed.
They reached across the biblical
rift for a selfish purpose.
And if they could, why not her?
Everything had been denied Ethel
her whole life-- to mission,
to help, to give love
in the way she wanted.
When the girl got
sick, the moment Ethel
awaited for so long
had finally arrived.
Ethel went upstairs,
as her father
had done, to confront the
stranger who lived in her house
as family.
The girl lay on the sheets,
curved like a primeval river.
She cleaned the girl,
washing her filth from her.
She kissed the girl on
her forehead and neck
in her restless slumber, with
two kinds of feeling mixed up
in those kisses.
She gave her the
holy word, a savage
to call her own at last."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So are there any questions?
SPEAKER 1: In 2012, you came
out with "11 Rules for Writing."
"Rule number two-- don't
go searching for a subject.
Let your subject find you."
You touched on this briefly,
but how did "The Underground
Railroad" keep finding you?
COLSON WHITEHEAD:
Well, I think, I really
thought 16 years ago
that was a good idea
and wanted to do justice to it.
And every couple years
when I took out my notes,
I would realize that I
was not up to the task.
That list of writing
tips is sort of
like a joke on the
sort of cliches
you hear in writing class.
But they contain a kernel of
truth, like a lot of cliches.
But I often tell my
students something
that I didn't remember
to apply to myself, which
is that if a story sounds
scary or too challenging
and beyond the scope
of your powers,
maybe that's the story
you should be writing.
Don't write the safe one
that you know you can do.
Write the story that
scares you shitless
and the one you don't
know you can do.
So I think that finally
brought me around
to tackle this 2
and 1/2 years ago.
SPEAKER 1: And so I
can't help but think,
so you're a New York author.
"The Underground
Railroad," you're
taking it from a metaphor to
being this very physical thing.
Did you think about
New York when you
were writing this book at all?
COLSON WHITEHEAD:
Well, probably not
when I first heard of
it in fourth grade.
I envisioned like
a subway tunnel.
And there is one
station in the book.
She goes through different
states and a couple
of different stations.
So some of them are very simple.
Some of them are hacked out
of the rock and very dim.
And then there's one that
is basically a New York
subway, with the
white subway tile
and could pass for a
station in New York.
So I've used the train as a
metaphor in my book "John Henry
Days," and the
elevator is a metaphor
in both "The
Intuitionist," which
is about elevator inspectors,
and that was actually
informed by being a New Yorker.
I'm not sure how
the rules are here.
But in New York, there's a
little sheet in the elevator,
and each year, the elevator
inspector signs his name,
and he comes around and
same signature, same person,
but different ink.
You go to school or work,
and they come and have
inspected your elevator.
So if you go to your
friend's house, the same guy.
It's like they have
beats, like cops.
So I thought, what if
an elevator inspector
had to solve a criminal case?
And so both that
book and this book
are partially inspired
by living in New York
and spending a lot of time in
elevators and trains, I guess.
SPEAKER 1: So we have one
question from the Dory.
Courtney wants to thank
you for being here.
She wants to know
how you decided
to have a female
protagonist tell the story?
The intersectionality between
gender and race during slavery
was incredibly complex.
What was more compelling to you
about the story a woman would
tell from this time
as opposed to a man?
COLSON WHITEHEAD:
Yeah, I always try
to mix it up from book to book.
So my book for this one
was basically a humor
book about the World
Series of Poker
and was crammed with jokes.
And this one has no jokes,
and I was definitely reining
in my more satirical impulses.
So keep that in mind-- my
last three protagonists
were men who were
very meditative
and break that cycle.
I think was important to have
someone who is not like that.
And then you write about the
intersectionality in slavery.
When you're a woman,
when you hit puberty,
you're expected to produce.
And that means producing babies
because more babies means
more hands to pick cotton.
More cot means more money
and more babies to sell.
And your body's not your own.
You're prey to the desires
of your master, other slaves.
There's no law on
the plantation,
except what exists according
to the whims of your owner.
So that was going to make
it a more complicated story
and a challenge.
And also, I haven't explored
a mother-daughter relationship
before in fiction.
And that's definitely
part of what drives
Cora to leave the plantation.
So I'm always trying
to try new things
and also create
challenges for myself.
And having a female protagonist
in this book was one.
And people say, is it hard?
All characters are hard
if they're believable.
They take a lot out
of you to make them
live and breathe on the page.
So I wouldn't say it was
more hard than having
a male protagonist.
If you're doing your job,
it should be difficult.
And if you do your
job, your protagonist
should be credible, whether
they're male or female.
So thanks for the question.
AUDIENCE: You've talked about
how it took you about 16 years
to write the book because
you weren't ready.
Can you talk a little bit more
about how it affected you,
how you had to grow
up or grow in some way
to be able to tell the story?
COLSON WHITEHEAD: Sure.
Well, I think, just
as a writer, I'm
always figuring out how
do things differently.
I think if you stick at
something for awhile,
hopefully you
become better at it.
So hopefully, I'm
a better writer
after a few books than
I was at the beginning.
So if I had written this
book maybe 5 or 10 years ago,
the different islands
would have taken place
with the fantastic effects
really sort of cranked up.
And I think, initially,
the South Carolina chapter
took place in the future.
The Tennessee chapter, which
has been ravaged by yellow fever
and wildfires, was
even taking place
in a more fantastic
wasteland, a sort
of post-apocalyptic wasteland.
And so instead of having
in rooted in 1850,
each time she got
in the train, she
was transported to a
different era as well.
And it just seemed that kind
of broad, fabulist gesture
didn't serve the story.
So by keeping it in
the idiom of 1850
and keeping it wedded
to Cora's point of view
and not deforming reality as
much as I initially planned,
worked out.
And that was the
value of waiting, so
waiting until I was capable
skill wise to pull it off.
And then I was 30 when
I had the idea, a sort
of jerky, Gen-X-y, douche bag.
I hung out late every night.
And I don't think I
had the sort of empathy
to animate a story like this.
It's one thing to contemplate
the horror of slavery
and think about what it's
like to see your parent stolen
from you, whipped
in front of you,
assaulted, seeing
your brother sold off,
your little brother sold
off to another plantation.
I think being a
parent allowed me
to access the
complexities of slavery
in a way I couldn't when I
was a callow 30-something.
So I couldn't imagine seeing
my kids assaulted and sold off.
I can appreciate the magnitude
of the horror now in a way
that I couldn't back then.
So I think I knew when I
was ready, and I did it.
And it took a bunch
years for me to have
a different perspective
on life and work
in order to pull it off.
SPEAKER 1: So the
"LA review of Books,"
in their latest review of
"The Underground Railroad,"
they called your perspective
"fundamentally ironic."
One, do you agree,
and how would you
balance that with the
historical traumas of the time?
COLSON WHITEHEAD:
No, but I mean,
definitely irony and satire
are big forces in my work.
So I think like everybody,
I have different parts
of my personality.
Sometimes I'm optimistic,
and sometimes I'm
more pessimistic or realistic.
And definitely in
the last couple books
I've been toggling between
those two different parts
of my personality.
"Sag Harbor" is a
very optimistic book
about a kid growing
up in the '80s,
and I followed up with a
book called "Zone One."
That was about 99% of
the population dying off.
And I think they
address different parts
of my personality
in different ways.
"The Noble Hustle," my previous
book before this one was,
was a jokey book about poker
and just a lot of jokes
and stupid humor in it.
And that's one part of me.
And then this book, "The
Underground Railroad,"
has no jokes in it.
It's quite bleak.
And so I think
like everyone else,
I have these different
trajectories in my personality.
I guess I'm developing a theory
about irony-- white irony
versus black irony.
I think white irony--
so much protesting this.
But white irony
is about realizing
that society's systems don't
work and are broken down,
and you're addressing that.
And I think black irony
is about realizing
the world systems don't
work, and they were never
meant to work for you anyway.
So there's an additional
sort of facet to it.
So definitely, in my
more satirical work,
I am sort of mining black
irony to animate the stories.
And I think that's
definitely there
in "Zone One" and "The
Intuitionist" and "John Henry
Days."
Is it in this book?
I'm not really sure.
And I think it's
pretty straight faced.
AUDIENCE: What's next?
COLSON WHITEHEAD: What's next?
I think it's going to be a
novel set in 1960s Harlem.
I'm always trying to write about
New York in a contemporary way,
but I keep failing.
"The Intuitionist"
takes place in an
alternative New York,
an alternative 20th century.
"Zone One" takes place
in a Utopian New York.
Everyone is dead, except
for the main characters.
They don't have to worry
about lines at Whole Foods
or waiting for a cab.
And then I was trying
to write this story
about a broken writer
that I was talking
about at the top of the hour.
But it didn't work.
I ended up abandoning
it for this.
So this book seems safe.
It takes place in the '60s,
not contemporary New York.
And when I'm done promoting
in the next spring,
I'll sit down and
figure out if it's
the one I should be working on.
So thanks a lot.
Thanks for listening,
and happy trails.
[APPLAUSE]